you're an incredible film nerd yeah I'm
just curious do other film nerds know
that you're a film nerd is the word out
the bill haters a film nerd yeah Wow
there they are see they follow me
everywhere it's like we found him ties
him Inessa ties him Polanski's take the
left
orson welles in there yeah they will
yeah yeah yeah I am I just had the TCM I
love the Turner Classic Movies and I
they just had their big festival and I
introduced a movie called Mad Love there
it's this great Peter Lorre movie and
afterwards I was a I went to go to the
restroom and there's a line and the guy
in front of me was said film nerd and
but he he he
a lot of times guys they just they they
they think that they could just be very
honest with me and they can only brought
and so the guy Amelie was like I've seen
your show and it's very derivative don't
you think and I was like okay and I'm
like I'm stuck with him and like we're
just moving up and I'm like both of you
are waiting to use a urinal yeah we're
both waiting for the urinals and I'm
just like going okay it goes very
derivative I mean I see Breaking Bad I
see get shorty I see gross point-blank I
mean I mean these all these other shows
that I a mean I feel like it's just a
pastiche really it's not really a thing
I was like well I guess that's that you
know that's your opinion man or whatever
and and then a urinal opened up and I go
hey man a urinal doesn't know that's you
man and he goes oh no I've got to take a
[ __ ] I'm waiting for the start
I'm not getting lucky with you I told
Alek Berg the co-creator buried this
story and al ago so you met the most
honest man in the world because I've
been in the position where so long ago
hey I'm not waiting first all right yeah
but no one says no I have to take your
[ __ ]
so that area will be required he gets in
the stall and he's like it's happening
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and that's one of those moments when you
do this really that you you that happens
to you and you go oh that's the talk
shows stories so you almost want to tell
him like I'm gonna talk about you on
Conan Dick